[Musique]
bienvenue sur exploitation à Saclay donc
on est agriculteur depuis plusieurs
générations sur le plateau de Saclay
donc on a connu les différentes
évolutions de liés à tous les enjeux de
la région et du territoire de Saclay
on a cherché un projet de
diversification par rapport aux grandes
cultures qui étaient qui étaient
produites sur l'exploitation donc on
produisait essentiellement des céréales
et du colza sur l'exploitation et on a
cherché à développer d'autres choses et
on s'est tourné assez rapidement vers le
maraîchage et la vente directe pour
valoriser notre espace agricole
aujourd'hui on a 25 hectares de fruits
et légumes cultivés donc à la fois une
partie sous serre une partie la plus
importante qui est en légumes de plein
champ et aussi une partie de vergers
principalement
c'est principalement une clientèle
locale qui qui consomme nos produits
donc qui habite dans les communes du
Plateau de Saclay ou limitrophes
quelques-uns viennent d'un peu plus loin
mais la grande majorité vraiment vient
du territoire également une petite
partie de la production est vendue sous
forme de panier dans les entreprises et
une autre partie sous forme de commande
groupée auprès des étudiants qui sont
tous arrivés sur le plateau de Saclay
comme on est parti de de zéro en 2010
quand on a commencé le projet il a fallu
déployer toute l'exploitation pour
qu'elle arrive à la taille actuelle et
finalement ça on a fait que accompagner
la demande des consommateurs et ça
marche principalement par du
bouche-à-oreille puisque on a juste
quelques informations des fois qu'on
diffuse sur les réseaux sociaux ou par
le bien de notre page internet de la
ferme mais
principalement c'est du bouche à oreille
des gens qui passent devant qui par
hasard qui connaissaient pas qui
s'arrêtent alors on se dit peut-être
qu'on répondait inatteinte des clients
enfin en tout cas nous on fait quelque
chose qui nous plaît aussi et c'est
surtout ça je pense qu'on a réussi à
trouver une diversification qui nous
plaît et on a réussi à proposer à
quelque chose qui plaît aux clients donc
c'est voilà donnant dedans
on parlait de plus en plus notamment par
rapport aux problématiques énergétiques
et de résilience des territoires le fait
de manger local ça fait déjà vivre un
agriculteur à côté de chez soi ça fait
vivre une économie agricole parce que on
a aussi toute une équipe autour de nous
qui qui travaillent et ça fait vivre un
territoire ça pour moi ça a du sens le
fait de manger local de saison ça permet
de manger sain et et sans non plus que
ça coûte forcément beaucoup plus cher
parce que quand c'est la saison voilà le
légume reste bon marché quoi le client
arrive dans le point de vente c'est la
surprise ah bah il y a ça ça y est la
saison a démarré
les légumes sont exceptionnels sont très
frais ils sont très beaux ils sont
cueillis de la veille ou de jours avant
et puis ça change forcément du
supermarché il y a une ambiance aussi on
se connaît tous on échange des recettes
avec des produits frais etc
on suit les saisons et puis les aléas
aussi du métier d'agriculteur la météo
qui est favorable ou pas favorable enfin
voilà on a des bonnes et des mauvaises
surprises avec la nature quoi
[Musique]